نعم، لقد جاء الجنود إلى سطح
منزلك هنا من سطح
شقته في جنين. يوضح لي محمد أبو الهيجا
المكان الذي خاضت فيه القوات الإسرائيلية
معركة استمرت ثلاث ساعات مع
مسلحين فلسطينيين على بعد بضعة أقدام فقط
حيث كان المنزل بأكمله هنا محاصرًا
من قبل القوات الإسرائيلية،
كان يوم الخميس من الأسبوع الماضي، أسفرت الغارة عن
مقتل 10 أشخاص، سبعة منهم
مسلح فلسطيني، وهي
واحدة من أكثر العمليات دموية في الضفة الغربية
منذ سنوات، اعتقد محمد أنه
وعائلته قد يموتون أيضًا لأن
القوات الإسرائيلية استولت على شقته
لمحاربة المسلح
الذي أظهره.  حيث يقول جنديان أطلقوا النار
من نافذته ليروا كل
ثقوب الرصاص على طول اه على طول الجدار هناك لقد
قضوا فوارغ الرصاص يقول
شهادة على ضراوة
القتال
يقول الجنود ربطوا يديه
خلف ظهره أمروه  وزوجته
على الأرض يغطون
أذني ابنتيهما، هذه إحدى
الرصاصات التي دخلت غرفتك
هنا
بدأ المسلح بإطلاق النار على
الجنود الإسرائيليين
فأصاب الجدار والباب بينما كان هو
وزوجته وابنته البالغة من العمر عامين  -بنتان تبلغان من العمر
سنة واحدة مرعوبتان على
الأرض، ويعتقد أن جنديًا واحدًا على الأقل قد
أصيب،
لذا قاموا بقطع هذا هنا نعم
وهناك ينظرون مباشرة إلى
المنزل، هذا هو المنزل المستهدف في
غرفة نومه  يوضح المكان الذي يقول فيه إن
الجنود قطعوا قضبان نافذته
وأطلقوا الصاروخ من
هنا وهذا هو الانفجار الذي حدث هنا
واهتز المكان بأكمله يقول إنه كان هناك
ثلاثة صواريخ وكان صوته مرتفعًا للغاية لدرجة أننا شعرنا بالرعب
وقال الجيش الإسرائيلي إنه كان
مهمة عاجلة، عندما وصلوا إلى
هنا، تعرضت قواتهم لإطلاق نار كثيف،
وردوا بإطلاق النار، كما يقولون، حيث تحصن
المشتبه بهم في
المنزل هنا، لذا أطلقوا
صاروخًا مضادًا للدبابات من الكتف عليهم،
مما أدى إلى إلحاق أضرار بالمسؤولين المحليين مما أدى إلى
هدمه باستخدام الشقق  كما قال
محمد، فإن إطلاق النار هو
إجراء تشغيلي قياسي،
وقال متحدث باسم الجيش الإسرائيلي لشبكة CNN حتى
يكون الإجراء أكثر دقة. ويقول
مسؤولو الأمم المتحدة إن الحادث ينتهك
القانون الدولي
في شقة الطابق الأرضي أسفل
زياد الذي يقول محمد إنه شاهد تبادل إطلاق النار ورأى
جنديًا إسرائيليًا  اختبأ خلف سيارته،
أطلق النار على أحد المسلحين،
هذا هو الأسوأ الذي رأيته
أسوأ بكثير من غارات عام 2002، يقول إن
هناك الكثير من المسلحين في الشوارع الآن، لقد أصبح جيلًا
أصغر سنًا، لقد ولدوا
فيه في
الطابق العلوي، محمد على وشك البكاء  عندما
أسأله عن مدى شعوره بالأمان،
نحن لسنا آمنين وغير آمنين للحظة
بعد ما حدث، يقول إذا كانوا قد
قتلوني فلن
يحاسبهم أحد، عليك أن تكون حذرًا للغاية
على الرغم من ندوب المعركة، فقد يبدو الأمر
كما لو أن البعض  بدأت الحياة الطبيعية
تعود ولكن في قلوب الناس هنا
هناك خوف من أن الأسوأ لم يأت بعد